the road to a cleaner and greener
Nigeria is very arduous every day
hundreds of thousands of cars try to
make their way through Lagos Africa's
biggest city and the traffic congestion
comes with a heavy cost the co2
emissions contribute to global warming
and rising sea levels and the toxic
fumes are a serious health hazard a
small company in Lagos decided to take a
first step
the owners have invested in
environmentally friendly electric
three-wheelers which are currently being
assembled in Lagos the vehicles are
suitable for taxi entrepreneurs delivery
services and use for haulage
the beautiful thing is is this clean
energy
it is electric very cool so no pollution
no additional cost to even the
entrepreneur because you know at the
cost of delivering your services it has
very limited changing path that you need
to replace when a module is bad then you
can easily replace it once you replace
it get back on the road fini oye says
the vehicles can drive up to 200
kilometres with a fully charged battery
customers can rent the vehicles one hour
will cost about the equivalent of two
and a half euros their company carbon
credit network is currently building a
network of solar charging stations along
all major highways in Nigeria even so a
mobility faces a lot of challenges in
Nigeria the power grid in the West
African country is still unreliable many
people here depend on generators but
using them to charge an electric car
would be senseless
in addition there's no public support
for the technology in Nigeria despite
those challenges the team says it's
undeterred the government does it think
in 30 years backwards when we need to
begin to look at how we want to get
position and take advantage it's just
the little push that is needed for
Nigeria to begin to achieve and stay at
the front burner of all of this
innovation and the changes that we want
to see carbon credit Network plans to
launch its services at the end of 2018
so far about 50 of the e vehicles have
been built the company wants to disrupt
the expensive and dirty transportation
system in Africa by offering a cleaner
and cheaper alternative if the federal
government builds a stable power supply
and devises policies to encourage
investments chances of success are good